right hey everybody welcome to another
hangout super excited to be talking with
you guys today about how to get results
from social media and I have a special
guest with me Brandon Olsen is the
content marketing manager for a weber
aweber is the comfort that I use for my
email marketing have done for the past
ten plus years so very loyal customer
and we're going to talk today about
social media and help answer your
questions so Brandon welcome aboard
thank you it's good to be here cool for
those of you who are new if you want to
ask us a question now a bunch of them
already came in but you can type / q and
then your your question and it'll show
up Brandon Before we jump into the
questions do you have any overall
theories or approaches or concepts that
you like to abide by that you use
yourself at a waiver but also advise I
know you of 120,000 some odd clients who
are using your stuff I need general
advice transfers before we dive in on
the specifics well I think you're
related to the topic of today's blab I
think you know whenever you're
connecting with your audience you're
trying to build an audience on social
media it's all about it's all about
relationships and connecting it's not
about selling so you go into it with the
mindset of I need to get someone to do
this that's the wrong approach you know
you need to start by building your
audience with trust and relationships
and in time you know that the results
will come so you know what comes to
social media that's kind of how I I look
at it is build those relationships and
don't always ask for something but
you'll start by giving something and
oftentimes it's education a little plug
for a weber you know where an email
marketing company we love helping
entrepreneurs grow and build their
audience and connect with them in in
really highly effective ways through
email and and so you know we kind of
carry what I mentioned about social
media and how you approach that we carry
that into our email marketing as well
encourage our customers to connect and
to build relationships because as you do
that that's when they're most engaged
and that's when your customers are are
more likely to
action when you ask them to do something
I love it what questions a porn in why
don't we dive in Julian how important is
it to automate social media content it's
a great question and it's you know
becoming more and more more and more
easy to automate everything you know I
think that's that's kind of going to be
the theme for the next couple of years
is automation and I'd say with
automating your your your social content
I think there's definitely definitely
advantages there and I would encourage
you to automate so if you're if you're
creating content it's so easy to use a
tool like HootSuite or sprout social and
to schedule out your content you know
days weeks in advance and there's also
tools that help you automate responses
and stuff on Twitter and I would just
you know it's a yes definitely you look
at automating as much as you can but a
little caveat little word word of
caution is be careful not to automate
too much because you know social media
is all about relevance and if you're if
you're automate if your automation is is
starting to make you irrelevant I mean
you're responding to something that is
completely irrelevant to what you know
what the what the person originally is
asking or what they said it doesn't make
you look very professional and doesn't
doesn't build that relationship of trust
that you're looking for so be careful on
the automation you know do certain
things that automate certain things but
you'll keep the conversations and stuff
it might be and keep those conversations
you know with you manual something that
you do our regular basis not not
automating that relationship yeah I
agree and I like the distinction between
the content that you're you're posting
and promoting versus the conversations
that you're having and I think you know
for example I post a youtube video it'll
automatically go to my Twitter and say
hey I posted in your youtube video but
the conversations I had I log in to my
youtube every day in my Twitter every
day and see what people are writing to
me and I respond and that's me a human
being answering them I think that's what
creates the caring so you can you can
automate the
schedule of your content the promotion
stuff but yeah the conversations you can
and so that balance is super important
absolutely great yeah you can't you
can't automate those conversations you
have to you have to do that one at a
time person by person cool dan Dane trim
boaters right in and Dane it's been a
while he's uh he's an awesome magician
there's a lot of corporate training and
based in Toronto here too with so many
social media platforms available how
does one decide where to devote one's
energy that's a really tough question a
lot of people struggle with that you
know that was some of it one of the
questions that came up a pre blab on the
Google+ page and the short answer I
guess is you know it depends oh no
that's not it's not a very great answer
but let me let me elaborate so you know
when when looking at all the platforms
you really have to decide and where your
audience is where's your target audience
and you may not know that right away so
it may take some testing and and trying
to find out where where your audience is
but it's good to start somewhere and
even if you're starting with an
assumption thinking about your audience
and your customers you know enough about
them to kind of start to understand
their interests and kind of what what
platforms they might be might be using
so start with that start with that
assumption and if you don't have that
answer you know you can you can easily
ask them send em a survey asking
questions when you're talking from one
on one what what platforms they use it's
also a good idea sometimes to use those
listening tools I can mention HootSuite
you know use HootSuite and start
listening in on on on conversations that
are going on on Twitter on Facebook to
see you know is there is a conversation
going on around my product around my
business that I could be a part of it
was my audience there and I think as you
start to dive into those things you'll
you'll start realizing yeah Facebook
might work linkedin is better for me
because there's it's more business focus
you start to understand kind of how
people are using them and where your
customers are it's also good to
understand kind of you know the
intentions that people have in using the
different platforms you know for
facebook for example where people are on
their connecting with their family and
friends they're looking for
entertainment you're looking for fun so
if you've got content that matches that
intent then definitely facebook might be
might be a place for you but if your if
your content is more business focus then
linkedin is probably a better better
focus for you because the mindset of
people on LinkedIn is is a business
mindset so think about the intent that
people have when they're on the
different platforms and does that match
your product is that match your content
that match your brand so that's another
good way to kind of think about it as
well I love it to the X to the to extend
the question Brandon mentioned that
someone had mentioned it earlier in the
Google page and that was Tamara weeks
who said is it ok to be on Twitter and
not on facebook to earth to be
everywhere and then Dan was in ask him
to follow up he's a professional speaker
what platform would fit well for him my
take on it i love i love brands approach
i think its marketing 101 is you know
you want to be where your customers are
if you're selling to salsa dancers you
want to be at the world's biggest salsa
convention so you know people business
ah needs to go to LinkedIn and
everything that then I sorry everything
that brain dementia was great the thing
that I would add to it would be I would
also try to match with what you're
really good at and where your strengths
are so as an example I love video I'm a
visual person that's how I like to learn
and I'd much rather be on video then
then record an interview or write a blog
post and so if my customers are in
multiple spots then I have a choice of
where am I going to be best at and so
then knowing your stuff and knowing
you're a great speaker and knowing that
you know you have great visuals that
would lend itself much better to a video
kind of audience so i would i would be
heavy on youtube much more than a blog
post kind of content with work out for
you so I think matching up where your
audience is combined with what you're
really good at and what you enjoy if
you're posting on Twitter because I
two posts on Twitter like you're never
gonna it's not going to work you got to
enjoy it like i enjoy YouTube I can't
wait to put my next I can't wait till
i'm going to upload this video to my
youtube channel and interact with you
guys so you have to love the process and
not just the outcome and i think some
platforms a better designed for
different personalities and so when you
figure that out if you could have
success and but then honestly for you I
Thank You Tube would be a good a good
platform to getting them I'd second that
and I also add one one last thing is in
addition to kind of following a platform
that that works for you you know I heard
Andrea Vahl say one time that you know
to stick to you know one or two
platforms that you do really well so
don't feel like you have to be on every
single platform find the one that works
for you the one or two that works for
you and really do it well and you know
Evans done a great job with his YouTube
channel because he's passionate about
and does it really well and so find that
niche for yourself find the platform
that works best for you and really
really put a lot of effort behind those
instead of spreading yourself too thin
across you know five or six or more
platforms hello alright Julian how can I
dance and fitness studio leverage
periscope that's a great one I see a lot
of a lot of people using periscope from
an educational standpoint you know chris
ducker and your father they're all on
using periscope these live broadcast
apps from an educational standpoint so
they'll jump on there and share some
tips share some education with their
audience and it's really all about
building your audience and and building
connections and strengthening that
relationship in that trust so for from
you for you and your example i see that
a lot of opportunities you know to to
share tips to share education with with
your audience and with your potential
audience yeah i think with periscope um
there's a couple things one you could go
the expert route which is what Brandon's
talking about you could you could be an
entertainer if there's a something fun
that's happening at your studio if i
want to join in and why
people doing their crazy dance moves
that might be something fun for me to
watch if there's a vibe that you're
trying to promote you know if you're all
about family and you're showing kind of
family moments I'm trying to create a
culture and you showcase that I think
being consistent would help to build up
your audience so you know I'm going to
do a periscope every day at nine o'clock
at night or whenever you're going to
have somebody kind of around that's kind
of interesting and that that trains
people to want to come back I think a
lot of people there's a lot of people on
periscope not as many on the business
side is a lot of like chillin on my back
porch you know and drinking beers or
whatever and there's a curiosity factor
there I think you want to the train and
audience and develop an audience you
have one of my consistent content and
let people know that they can tune in
every day or every week at this time
people to see you that's second way
great ah cool but again a lot of live
questions avoiding any of the other ones
yeah and to ask question guys are going
to /q and then you can type it in spy
gadget rentals my friend owns a sandwich
shop how can he use social media I think
this kind of relates to what we had
talked about earlier finding the right
you know find the right place for for
participating in social media so for a
sandwich shop you know if you're working
with a lot of local local audience so
Facebook would be a great a great place
to start our I think because you can
create your pages that are local pages
and you know do a lot of things within
your sandwich shop to you know drive
people to your Facebook page to build
that Facebook audience you know offering
deals and things on Facebook as an
encouragement to build that Network is
another big one a good place to start
you know so I think again it's hard to
say exactly where to start because I
don't know your audience as well as you
do or as well as your friend does but
look at your audience and start asking
you know you got customers coming into
this out shop every day ask them you
know where where
like to hang out on social media is at
Facebook is it Instagram and start
getting a better understanding of where
your customers spend most of their time
so that you can start deciding where to
invest your time and effort in social
media yeah I'd be looking at two things
I would one try to think about what kind
of content i want to put out what are
you an expert at are you the healthy
sandwich shop are you the delicious
sandwich shop are you the you know am I
going to come every day to your shoppers
like a once a month kind of treat kind
of place that is insane on the calories
you know what what what are you staying
for is a store or you just another
sandwich shop right what's the expertise
that you bring and then try to share
those thoughts as opposed to just saying
hey come by our store and two for one
deal on thursday afternoon you know if
you build up personality so i get to
know you like you trust you then i'm
much more likely to want to come back to
your store the other thing is using
facebook specifically you can target
like no other platform now it's much
more pay to play compared to other
networks but i'd be looking at people
who know who's your demographic you know
are they younger people who are
health-conscious because you can target
them right so if i wanted to target
people who are 25 to 40 who like to run
and who are vegan and who live in Dallas
because that's where your sandwich shop
is I can do it on Facebook right I can
target those guys and show them a
message no other platform gives you that
level of granular detail to reach out
and target people so I've been looking
at both strategies looking at like a
content strategy expert point of view
and then also direct campaign marketing
through Facebook dark posts Michael D
Haynes where does blab fit into the
social media spectrum well well that's a
great question i'm a i'm a newbie to
blab i know some of my colleagues I've
are more familiar with it i spent a
little more time on it but from my
observation and i'm sure everything can
speak of it marked my observation you're
the benefit of labs and periscopes and
these live
test platforms is the ability to connect
with your audience in a real-time
immediate way where you can have a
conversation and and start building a
community so I think you know in my view
the benefit of lab is is being and
blabbing these other platforms is to
really start connecting and putting a
face and start being a conversation in
your community in your audience where
you're strengthening that relationship
and that tie with them yeah I think
there's something about live I think
it's just going to get more and more
important I know a lot of you have come
from a youtube channel and you're used
to seeing my videos and most of the
videos I put up or the standard you know
I have a videographer they're polished
here you know it's live i'm just i'm
standing here i'm answering questions
live you know we got Brandon on the line
here you never know what's going to
happen and I think just ability to
connect with people quickly and get
answers to your question is something
people care about I like blabbed on a
bunch of gun periscope I've done
hangouts it's still do hangouts I do lab
I like blab because the interaction I
like that people can also call in if we
take live questions I like the you can
see everybody i like the you can give
you know props to people and then you
can still download the video and upload
it to youtube or wherever else you want
to upload it as well so it's still a
it's a you know it's obviously a newer
plate of the game but I'm a fan and it's
great to see like the questions pop up
and we'll see where it goes we'll see
how grow how quickly they grow who ends
up acquiring them but it's a fun
platform it's just a lot more fun I find
then the other platforms are doing live
events Julian's asking her this is a
really the question for for a weber is
it crucial to build a list on social
media for example sending routing people
to your site and getting them on your
newsletter or have them subscribe folio
on that specific platform specific
social media platforms how important is
it to build a list from your social
media platforms i'm always a fan of
building less and your social your
social content should be helping that
effort
so you know I i think it is crucial I
mean your your number one goal in in a
Weber's opinion is to build that list
because you're if you build that list
it's a list you own you control how
often and how and how much you are
communicating and connecting with your
with your subscribers but if you know
where as opposed to social media you're
serving at the mercy of whether Facebook
decides to show your boats to your
audience or whether your tweet shows up
and someone's you know you know
multitude of tweets that are coming you
know flying down their newsfeed so with
an email with us you know it's your list
you own it you determine how often and
what you send and to whom you send those
those emails which is why it's been
proven to be one of the most effective
marketing tools or channels that you can
really employ as a busy search so you
know I think part of your social media
strategy or approach needs to needs to
be yes you'll building your social
audience but also getting them to you
know go that one step further and become
a subscriber so that you're able to
communicate them communicate with them
in a way that you want to versus you
know being at the mercy of the social
networks I totally agree and everything
I do in social my funnel leads to my
newsletter like at the end of the day
you want to generate business right you
want to sell more you want to get more
deals but the people who just push that
on social you don't get results because
nobody wants to follow you my goal for
every social network that I have is to
get people on to my newsletter list
because email is still the best way in
my view to get in front of somebody
right once you have permission to email
them because you open up emails you see
an email from Evan Carmichael and
hopefully you guys open that up I'm
thinking about for those are you
watching how many of you came here
because I emailed you that's probably
why most of your here wasn't because I
tweeted it or made a video about it
you're here on this thing right now
because I emailed you and that's still
where I get most of the results you want
somebody to take action right away you
want to build them on your email list so
you look at my videos you know
we have 200,000 subscribers in the
videos and 20 million views at the end
of every video is a link to sign up for
my email list that's what I want people
to do yes and when you subscribe yes
won't you leave comments yes I want you
to watch more videos but by watching
like three or four videos your next step
is going to be sign up for the email
list and then I'm going to send you not
just sales stuff there's still tons of
value and we could talk about like that
I guess later I know we did that in the
last session when somebody puts out a
tweet you don't follow that person most
of the time so closely that you read
every single tweet that they put out
right it just gets lost in the fire hose
but with email somebody sends you an
email somebody named that you recognize
you still open that up and you take
action and so I run my entire funnel
through my email list and then that
leads to business so social email
business yeah absolutely i will add to
that you know that the inboxes is pretty
coveted people know they they're pretty
pretty tight without who they let in to
their inbox so when they add you to your
list when they when they add get added
to your list it means that they want to
be that they want your they want your
contact they took that step to invite
you into their inbox so it's remember
that that relationship building that's
sort of the the path that that
relationship takes is you your tracking
them on social you're starting to build
that relationship and then the next step
in that relationship is for them to
really become a subscriber and and start
communicating with you directly love it
dan has a follow-up question do you have
suggestions for ways to convert your
social media audience into list members
that's a great question and there's tons
of ways down some of the ways that we
see the most effective from our
customers is as Piper yell what it boils
down to his value you know are you
offering your audience value so that
comes with understanding your audience
what their interests are what they find
valuable and then providing that so you
know it could be in the form of an
incentive it could be a discount coupon
it could be an e-book that could be
joining a webinar or it could just be
simply you know you know subscribe to
our blog to get you know
daily updates daily tips on building
your business so it's all about defining
what your what the value is for your
customers where can they what do they
find a value and then delivering that so
I you know those are some examples of
things that we've seen our customers do
effectively and it's really going to
depend kind of how you determine you
know what the value is for your
customers and for your audience that's
really going to attract and convert
those social or social audience into
subscribers yeah I love that point I
think I think you have to date before
getting married and I think social media
social media is like passing somebody on
the street and then then email marketing
is like dating and then and then you get
married when that you buy something in
our customer and so you know how do you
go from just meeting somebody on the
street to to getting their number and
going on a date you know you gotta
provide value just in the social media
stuff right so the tweets you're putting
out the videos you're putting out the
blog post you put an out has to be
interesting enough to say wow this
person has some cool content because i'm
not going to subscribe to somebody's
email list if I didn't like really like
the tweets right passing by shiraz cool
i'll retweet that or like that but am I
going to now spend time to read emails
from them every week right that's a new
level so you have to be provide enough
consistent content to make me want to go
that next step with you an easy way to
kind of bridge that gap is offer some
kind of bonus that's in the email that
ties to what you're posting on social so
as an example uh you know if you have a
cooking channel and you're making the
YouTube video that talks about a recipe
you're making you could give the recipe
away if they sign up for your newsletter
right side of a newsletter and I always
email up my recipe so they can watch and
follow along in the video but to
actually get the printed recipe out then
the sign up for your newsletter so Dan
your speaker you know maybe you have
your five pillars that you talk about in
your speeches you can make videos about
it and you can you know blog about it
and you can tweet about it but then for
buying signing up for your newsletter
you get the printed manifesto that then
I can you know put on my wall right
under the believe logo i have like
Dane's manifesto here and I got that
because I sign up for your newsletter so
some kind of extension of value based on
what you're already talking about and
social but you got to build the
relationship up first if you just jump
to that just say sign up for my
newsletter nobody's going to come
because you haven't quite enough value
first cool the questions are flying in
we had the other questions to is insane
everybody allows you brand and this is
the hot topic okay new future builder do
you have any examples of truly unique
Facebook Instagram Twitter posts as in
they have unique yet consistent formats
that catches the eye and attention mmm
Facebook Instagram Twitter well that's a
good question I follow a few brands
larger brands on Facebook Instagram and
I feel like biggie a good job of having
a consistent format a consistent look
design and I'm not sure I see some of
the smaller companies smaller businesses
doing that and I guess that's an area of
opportunity for them one one that I
really love on Facebook is is Oreo who
doesn't love Oreos but they do a really
good job of like keeping a really
consistent look and feel from for all
their posts and its really engaging
content as well because they understand
their audience and they spend people
love cookie so show them cookies show
them interesting things about cookies so
yeah I think you know nothing else kind
of boxing in my mind right off the bat
Oreos one that I really loved watching
on facebook that I think they do a
really great job of that one thing I
will mention i mentioned earlier in the
in the chat here that and we do a weekly
email chat on twitter and Olivia are our
social media specialist she does a great
job of making a look and feel of the
email chats consistent so every week you
know when you're there you know you're
in email chat so i think there's there's
an opportunity there to with your
content to to bring some consistency to
it so that they recognize that it's
yours that it belongs to you and
and and they can expect that I think for
my end i'm not a huge consumer on any of
those platforms Facebook Instagram
Twitter I'm pretty active on Facebook
and Twitter and not really Instagram
mostly just in responding to people like
if somebody leaves a comment or mentions
me I look at my twitter feed every day
and I'm responding to people but I'm not
a consumer uh the only people that I
really pay attention to are either my
clients or my friends and I don't know
there's anybody was like massively
amazing content that i would highly
recommend to you for me I'm a consumer
on YouTube which reflects me being all
in on youtube as well and one of the
only channels that I consistently watch
most of the content from is Gary
Vaynerchuk he's a guy out in New York he
does a lot of talks a lot about social
media so a lot of you guys would get
value from watching his channel and it's
not so much that it's amazing graphics
or design or you know special effects or
anything and he's not even not
consistent like he may have three shows
a week and then one show week and then
five shows a week he jumps all over the
place just the content is good it's
interesting it's interesting to hear
what he's doing his perspectives so i
don't know if that i don't know if that
kind of helps you too much on answering
that question but I mean that's where
I'm a consumer and I'm a user and the
other ones are like video game stuff
like League of Legends tutorials and
stuff otherwise those are the only ones
that are like I watch every video that
these guys put out a shoe bomb how can
the small business how can the small
business can use the this and how I'm
not following this and they don't have
enough knowledge about the website
building in the newsletter how can you
manage it so i guess the small business
getting started trying to build a
newsletter trying to build a website
it's kind of over their head what are
your thoughts and a new be getting
started well there are so many resources
out there that that can help you get
started now i know i can speak from a
weber's perspective we provide a lot of
taunton a lot of education on on how to
get started with email marketing
as well as you know some of the other
marketing channels like building your
website how that connects to your email
marketing so you know for the selfish
plug you can go subscribe to today Weber
blogging and get regular information and
updates on how to build your list and
how to how to use email marketing
effectively but you know i would i would
start with and just just searching
there's there's tons of resources out
there yeah i think you could probably go
to some of those education you know
sources like Linda calm or some of those
other free training areas no I haven't
I'm not sure if you've got any other
resources where they can go to to some
good ones for building yeah I mean I
think it's never been easier to start a
business online you know websites have
never been easier to set up I would
honestly I was starting now has zero
technical knowledge I would just start a
wordpress site and you can you can get a
free template or you can pay 50 bucks
and get a really nice-looking template
and if you can use word you can use
WordPress it's super simple and then for
newsletter since you asked about it
obviously I've used a weber it used to
be I mean it's so easy to set up now I
was on ten plus years ago where you have
to have HTML experience and you design
your own forms and it was a lot harder
now there's so many preset farms and
graphics and best practices that you can
you know they'll they'll design the
thing for you pick I'm a real estate
agent okay here's a theme for real
estate agents and there's a picture of a
house on it and free report is already
on there like it's so easy to set up now
that the tools are available I think
just I would honestly combine that I
would look at I would look at a
wordpress and then Aweber for the
newsletter and you're off and running
and you don't need to have like used to
have to have a programmer on staff to
run a website now you don't need anymore
and the tools are only getting easier
sometimes I still default back to the
technical ones because I'm used to them
let go the added all these things hmm
I'm so used to this so we've already set
up templates and formats for
it's cool to see all the new stuff that
you guys are coming out with any
thoughts with communication customer
service tech tech sales support using
texts using so text messaging as a
marketing communication oh well I
wouldn't consider text messaging social
media but in flats on communication
using text hmm well I've seen I've seen
contests and promotions done through
text I've seen a live text happening at
conferences live events you know and
then obviously you know you get you know
your your customer service and tech
support text from you know your your
phone provider and your other utilities
and stuff so I think that's an effective
way to communicate I think you have to
be careful about how how frequent you're
using that medium because it is so
instantaneous you don't want to be using
it for everything otherwise your
subscribers or customers will find it
annoying and we'll find it you know
disrupting order of the day so just just
be mindful of how often how immediate
that communication channel is being used
you know there's kind of two think about
all the different communication channels
that you have some more passive like
email that you'll read it when they when
they want to when they have time to wear
as you know if X is surrounding your
phone instantaneous so it better be urge
and it better be important so you know
but those are my thoughts on
communication through texts yeah I think
one depends on your audience like any
marketing right as your audience are
they younger they walking around with
phones you know especially for a retail
location and you can do like jus
targeting taxa case somebody's within a
mile of my sandwich shop that sandwich
guy that we had on earlier right
someone's a little mile and they've
opted into my text
Jane and I can invite them into have
soup and a sandwich here right that
could potentially be pretty powerful I
don't use I mean my business now is
online so I don't have text marketing
with my Toronto dance salsa business
that that is a potential option right
people who are within a certain block
radius just make sure again that it's
opt in and be careful what the message
is you're putting out because the phone
is is a sacred place just like it's just
like an email inbox right and if its
value and relevant then I'm going to pay
attention to it but if you're just
blasting me just like you know you can
say build a list but if all you're doing
is blasting people with spam you're
going to your list is going to get
unsubscribe pretty quickly so make sure
you treat it really carefully and give
people what they want yeah I also add
that to make sure your expectations are
set up front so if you're if they're
opting in to receive text or you make it
clear what they're going to be getting
otherwise you know if you're starting to
deliver things that are not what they
expected you're going to start getting
compliance here and start getting some
unsubscribe so be very clear on what
your what they're going to what we can
expect to get and then deliver on that
expectation cool we've had a bunch of
people trying to make video calls in so
why don't why don't we take home we've
got Tamra weeks we answer the question I
think from her earlier on let's see if
you can join in and hit us with a
question while she's joining I see
Michael is asking about if a Weber has a
word clutch a wordpress plugin on video
we're actually going to be posting a
blog post about it on our blog either
later today or tomorrow about about the
plug-in but it's really easy to use next
right away and you're able to pass your
subscribers right into your into your a
weber list from your wordpress site
that's pretty cool I didn't know about
that I need to know about then I'm gonna
use a tip I'll be a user all right okay
look it we've got the other questions to
from the Google sheet before oh there's
hammer how you doing I'm good how are
you tell us quickly about what you're
doing and then hit us with the question
all right this
is Tamra weeks with tams daily vlog i
have i am a daily vlogger on youtube and
first I really want to tell you I love
giving you high fives but my hands are
not touching anything it's incomplete
auto looks like it's just doing it all
by itself all right somebody was annoyed
and wanted me to stop and I can't um I
have a question about websites i have a
website it is currently down I don't
really have like a business per se so
i'm not selling anything I'm not doing
consulting but I have a daily youtube
channel everybody always in you guys at
the beginning talks about the importance
of a website what do I put on the
website I used to just put my videos on
there but I mean if you just want a
video you just come to my youtube
channel I don't know what to do with a
website why do I need one it's great
question okay yeah haha so I think a web
sites or your destination you know
YouTube is they're constantly updating
it with with fresh content but like Evan
was saying earlier the way that he uses
this YouTube is always the builders list
so he's always wearing his YouTube
channel to building that list so mmm so
your website to have some excuse me your
website can have information about about
who you are what you eat you can is all
about what you do what makes you unique
what sets you apart and then yeah you
can also use your website as as a means
to build that list of subscribers email
subscribers and it doesn't have to be a
really elaborate or or intense website
it could be very simple and very basic
but just making it really clear you know
who you are and what I'm doing and
giving them a reason that value that we
talked about to become a subscriber
whether it's yogi got something unique
or something exclusive or you know if
there's something else that you're
offering with your youtube videos just
making sure that that value comes
through when we're when you're you know
with those website goes over yeah my
view
be i would start thinking about this as
a business right you started off saying
this is in the business of just a
YouTube kind of like start treating this
like it's a business and think about hey
I want to start be able to earn an
income we make money through this and
what a business model might look like
right now you check building up your
person grand so people get to know you
like you trust you but as you build an
audience I can develop into a bunch of
other opportunities right you could
create products you could do speaking
engagements right all of these things
and help and if you ever want to send
keep a somewhere right then you want to
have an email list to be able to say hey
I'm going to be doing this blob come
join me right I know you mention that
you found us here because the email that
I sent you even though you follow me on
Twitter even though you subscribe to my
youtube channel you're on here now
because I emailed you right and so so
many entrepreneurs make the mistake of
starting to build their list too late
and so you've already started your I
would say look as a business you've
already started it now you building up
your personal brand another website that
talks about you your story even you can
find out more about you like why did you
start this why is this interesting you
may have made a video on it but it could
be buried you know 20 videos back and
I'm not going to go through that backlog
to find it so you could put on your
website and tell me more about who you
are what you're all about and have a
newsletter list I'll make me send up or
I'm going to give value on an ongoing
basis even if you're just sharing I mean
you top videos I couldn't begin your
newsletter because again videos are
missed I think though I subscribe to you
what am I you to be and there's I
subscribe to a hundred channels yours
might not show up in the algorithm today
right so any mostly here's your top
video makes me tie to you and then when
you have an announcement that you want
to make you want people coming to check
out your new book that you're watching
or whatever it is you have those
subscribers on your email list I value
my email they subscribers way more I
love my YouTube subscribers but like if
I need something to get done it's
happening through my email not through
any of my social media platforms okay
that really does help rule that's the
Merse to that that don't necessarily
have a full-blown website that just use
really landing pages for the incentives
that they offer to build their list so
that's another option to consider as
well it's not
not necessarily needed whole website you
can you lend pages as well the build-out
less okay can I ask just one more
question sure we just want her okay so I
have a question about privacy and how
you feel about this so I have a youtube
channel and I have like a fan page on
Facebook that's not active it's
literally just you know my videos go on
there and if people comment i always
respond then I my personal facebook page
but I'm finding that a lot of my YouTube
scriber subscribers are coming over to
be friends on my personal facebook page
I'm totally okay with that but I'm
really wondering as this grows is that
really okay like there's nothing really
private anyway but just kind of what is
your what is your take on that so I'm
one a believer in creating a facebook
page I do not believe you should be
using your personal profile for your
business or for your community and be
right not necessarily just for privacy
reasons but for all the above all the
abilities you have with a facebook big
versus a profile and raval talks about
this all the time about why it's
important to fill the page versus of
profile and for your business there's so
many advantages that you have by using a
Facebook page which is a profile for
marketing and for reaching your audience
and then there's also a privacy
discussion as well which is also
important thing to consider you just
never know who who you're connecting
with definitely so always always drive
the drive your followers to connect with
you using a Facebook page versus a
profile ok cool uh so some people had
aren't i'm hearing the question thank
you tomorrow so we'll answer i'll just
click it for now but will answer yours
on the video I the question was about
privacy and whether you should do a
Facebook page personal or business or
both and how to make that work for me I
have both and i use facebook for myself
as a husband and a father
friend and a son for the personal side
of stuff and then i use my business page
for posting videos and comments and
connecting with the fans and i keep that
separate so if I haven't actually you
know met you then you're not on my
personal facebook page and I get people
ask all the time they're joining as a
personal friend I just ignore it um
that's just how I divided rather to be
on the facebook page and not on my
personal facebook alexander do you have
tips on starting with affiliate
marketing uh yeah we've got lots of tips
that we do I mean we have an affiliate
program here de weber and and we have
lots of affiliates that that are that
are part of our program and when you're
starting with affiliate marketing I
think it's important to align with your
passions you have to really stand behind
what products or services you are your
affiliate for you know and that's where
I've seen the most success from from our
affiliates is when they're really
passionate about what they what they're
what they're offering as as an affiliate
and it also needs to align with kind of
what your what your business is so you
know it wouldn't make sense for me to
become an affiliate to you know a food
you know the food industry when i when
my business has nothing to do with food
so make sure that you're whatever
affiliate programs you're part of are
aligned with what your business is and
what your passions are is you really
have to be able to stand behind it if
you really want to make it work and then
as far as you know actually becoming an
affiliate and doing it effectively we've
got lots of really effective and
successful affiliate John Corcoran's one
of them you know they do a good job
because they're incorporating that their
affiliate information and content into
their into their overall and ongoing
communication so you know when it when
you match your affiliate program and
your end
you're the product your affiliate for
with your business and your passions and
you're in it and so natural to talk
about that because that's what you do
and become super easy to to really grow
your affiliate marketing efforts ya
Alexander if you're not using it don't
sell it if you wouldn't recommend it to
your mother to use don't sell it right I
think too many people jump into
affiliate marketing or network marketing
just trying to make a quick buck and it
never works out you got to actually love
the stuff throw the business model the
model is fine but you actually have to
have passion for what you're selling
just like brand new was talking about I
think so the avenue of this hangout is
talking about social media what i would
do is if i was trying to market some
affiliate products i would think in my
final like we talked about earlier on we
got my social media I want to draw
people to my newsletter list and then
from the newsletter list provide value
and then also sell the affiliate
products right Aweber has an amazing
affiliate program which gives you
ongoing commissions and referrals which
is great if I was going to promote that
I'm not just going to go up on Twitter
and say sign up for this socialist this
newsletter software right now right like
nobody's going to do that right but if i
put it out to my newsletter list I could
probably convert a whole bunch of people
to then sign up for my referral program
but I would leave that with content like
I'd have to talk about how I use email
why I use email why is beneficial for
you to ease email and here's the tool
that I use Susie well that I've been
using for 10 years and i highly
recommend right just like we're doing on
you guys are curious about email maybe
some of you will go and check out a web
right now because we've had this
conversation you've got the me breathing
is a nice guy as answering questions
we're giving you value if I just post it
to my to my Twitter or YouTube saying go
sign up for a weber now most of you
wouldn't take any action and so I've
been looking at what are the products
that are repping what's the vibe I'm
getting from them share valuable content
on social media draw people to my
website to my newsletter and then in
there I would have my pitch to make them
be interested in the products i'm
selling yeah I second that completely
how do I double check to make sure a
third party companies actually
sending out my newsletter um so third
party company I guess I could read into
that two ways you know one you're using
you know a third-party service like
aweber or you're using an agency a third
party to actually you know do your email
marketing for you with aweber if you're
using a third-party service like aweber
you can you can you get all the
analytics that come with with your email
marketing so you send out your
newsletter you see right away you know
how many were delivered huzhou company
opened it who's opening it whose
clicking it so all that data is right in
your account when you're using a third
party you know marketing provider like
whoever you're using a third party like
an agency or a virtual assistant you
know i would i would assume that you'd
have access to to log in to your queue
whatever system they're using so that
you can confirm that you know they're
actually sending those things your
newsletters and emails so I think it's
really simply simple to double check
that you know either for any in either
scenario yeah I would also say just on a
qualitative way like are you getting
responses you know is your email when
you send out an email newsletter you're
supposed to get replies right if it's
any good so are you getting responses on
an ongoing basis um you know you he just
wrote in the comments that it's an
agency that is hired through alliance um
so I'd also be careful like how how are
you building that list that you rely on
them to say hey I'm gonna email 10,000
people and promote your product it's
probably not a massively effective way
you'll just spam people um but yeah they
should be giving you reports and updates
and you should see results right like
email marketing works so if you're not
getting results and your content isn't
good or you're not targeting the right
people it's just framing people on the
list um yeah and you know I think also
you want to get to the point with your
email newsletter where if you don't post
an email out people will write to you
right if I don't post you know people
are used to my news that are coming out
every week and I had a week where I just
I didn't have time I was always
traveling and I forgot to send it out
and enough time and people would write
and say hey Evan did i miss your
newsletter to go to San what happened
nothing came in that's when you know
you're actually posting something that
people look forward to and as a value
and your aim should be to create content
that's that's so good that if you don't
post it they miss you and they write to
you so either way you're getting the
response a response to a newsletter or
response that you haven't sent your
newsletter oh that's gotta email us you
need yeah I like it um oh there was the
question just pop down let's see as a
river ever thought of letting newbie
start for free or until X summer
subscribers are reached you started what
is it nine dollars so are nineteen
dollars you know there's art and that's
up to 500 subscribers Google we do a 30
day free trial to allow though people
who want to kind of kick the tires and
see if it's the right solution for them
we have you know which we thought about
it we've talked about you know a free
option but we decided not to not to do
that now if you look at other free
providers you know yeah you do get a
free account and the abilities to email
but you know you're not getting all the
all the suite of features but when
you're in your sign for you ever even
though it's not free you get everything
there's there's really no add-ons or up
sells you know ever every customer gets
the same same features the same
functionality as everybody else so
there's nothing that you know that you
have to be worried about when you sign
up for whoever whereas other free
providers you may get very limited
abilities with your email marketing
either a smaller list or you know
they're there they don't let you send as
much email or maybe the automation
features aren't there so you know that's
that's something to consider as well
yeah you want to make sure this is just
applied to email whatever providers
you're working with you want to make
sure that you can grow with them and
they're going to be able to help you
longer term
when you look to email it sucks to have
to switch providers it really sucks at
port your list over and whether
everybody moves over they probably won't
you lose a whole bunch of subscribers
but more importantly it's finding
companies that with the long term
perspective you think you can work out
with them just as a as a example with
the salsa company that i have i'm
looking at a studio software for them
and you know it's a hundred bucks a
month or something and you like we can
give you the first two months for free
or something like that some kind of
promotion I don't care about the first
two months are free I care if i move my
entire company over this software and it
goes wrong or something that's worth way
more than 200 bucks right and so I want
to make sure that I line what's up with
the right company that as I grow they're
going to be there for me it's the right
solutions I don't want to keep having a
hop and switch um and so free for 30
days 19 bucks a month you know you
should you should more than make up for
that in your first month as you're
driving people on and then selling
whatever product or service that you
have and then know that you have a
company that you can work with and grow
my list is almost 80,000 people you can
continue to grow and build build your
list up and it's a yes I'm I'm I'm one
sided always see because I've been a
loyal Aweber customer for X number of
years but but let me tell you it's not
also because we're doing this hangout
this is like a hashtag Real Talk moment
I only promote the stuff that I actually
use and as an example was on a twitter
chat with Microsoft and they asked me
what is my one of my favorite
productivity apps and one of the ones I
mentioned was Evernote and they freaked
out because they have one note which is
a competitor to Evernote and he said you
can't talk whatever note said this is
what i use you ask you what i use i'm
going to answer it honestly write and so
sometimes that works out my favorite
sometimes it doesn't but it always works
out in your favor like I use Aweber I
haven't looked at a different email
provider for 10-plus years I'm happy
with it and so my view 19 bucks a month
to get started yes I get it like if you
are the very start every dollar counts
but I'd much rather work with the
company where I'm not going to have huge
pain down the line with and porting
lists and the services
insanely outstanding um so there you go
that's not real talk rent my rent for
the day Jerry is it necessary to create
multiple social media profiles example
Twitter for business with a personal you
need to create multiple multiple we kind
of covered that with the facebook one
but what are your thoughts about
creating accounts on like you need to
have every account on every social
network should you have this instagram
account should you have their god i
think that there's some value and at
least getting in there and getting a
feel for it to really understand how it
works and you don't need to go create
you know profiles for all your on all
the platforms for your business but i
think there's some value in jumping in
personally and just kind of getting a
feel for how it works and the type of
people that are there so that you can
make a really educated and wise choice
on on where to invest your time so i do
believe that and I do that myself just
to kind of get a sense of the platforms
and what their advantages disadvantages
are and when you decide you know you
know that's the right channel you know
say Instagram for example is right for
my business then yeah I go ahead and
create a personal and as well as a
business profile for for your business
there so I think you know just
determining kind of where to invest your
time is sort of that next step you know
first get a feel for it decide whether
it's the right platform for you and then
really start investing the time you know
if you're if you're if you have a
business you create a business profile a
lot of people are sort of their own
personal brand and so you wouldn't
necessarily you know need to create
another business profile necessarily
could be your personal profile if you're
sort of that personal brand so I think
you know I think it is necessary to
create sort of separate profiles for
business and personal I'd start with
personal get a feel for it first and
determine whether it's right right fit
for your business and then make the time
and investment to you know build it for
your build a profile and a presence for
your business as well
you know to add to that I would say you
would want to have the account on every
social network even if you don't use it
just to avoid squatters you know I
thought Twitter was stupid at the start
people talking about their cats and what
date for lunch and it's like you know
I'm a busy entrepreneur I don't have
time it's great entertainment awesome
but I got I'm not gonna send my time
here but I still went and got Evan
Carmichael because if I decide to go on
and I don't want to be Evan Carmichael
23 right I want to be Evan Carmichael
right and so it's like it's a it's a
land grab always at the start when these
things come out so I would just go and
grab it doesn't cost you anything in
cost you five minutes of your time just
to make sure that you have it and you
can use it for potential future use uh I
would split the personal business only
if you really feel a personal need like
on facebook I feel a lot of my friends
around there my family's on there so I
have a personal need and so I created my
own personal Facebook I don't have a
personal need on Twitter like twitter is
my public persona it's my business side
I don't I don't have anything i would
put on that I would have just like
protected tweets or anything for my
friends so I don't I don't have a need
to do it so i don't so i just be looking
at what networks first like get the land
grab get your name and every network and
then if you have a personal need then
you can also create a personal side ah
blue lindsay blue Lindsay what would be
a piece of advice that you know now that
you would give your beginner self to be
able to so to be able to manage your
social media as a business and make
income from it in the most effective way
from the start whether it be physical
physiological management or whatever
thank you advice to your younger self
Brandon but younger self would probably
say now that I know that I've got a lot
of social me experience and I've been
working with Aweber for a while now I
think we mentioned this earlier but you
know if you're looking to make income
and in a most effective way from the
start is building your list so you know
everything you should be doing for a
marketing sample it should be with the
end goal of building out
because that's how you are reaching your
your customers your potential customers
your audience the most in the most
effective way so from the get-go make
sure that you're building a list you
don't have to have you know everything
all in order you know everything lined
up exactly other what in other words
don't delay building your list just
because you don't have an autoresponder
series all fleshed out or your email
marketing strategy all taken care of
start your start your building the lists
from the get-go even if it's a little
rough and you're not sure exactly how
you're going to use the list build it
start building it and then you know over
time you'll start to really understand
how how you want to use your email
marketing in the most effective way
that's what my piece of advice is to
really start building that less first
and social medias is one way of doing
that and it's a really effective way as
you are able to now turn those passive
gates into or those passer by's into
into official dates like everyone was
talking about it earlier yeah i think i
think too many entrepreneurs don't have
they don't necessarily see themselves as
a business yet they don't see social
media as a business and so I haven't
figured out the funnel the funnel of
social media to your website to your
newsletter to then your income in your
sales um I wouldn't give that advice to
my younger self because I came from
business background and I started doing
that right so it's not like I wish I
started doing my list earlier but I
think that is it it's like super viable
even for like Tamara who we had on the
show didn't think that she was an
entrepreneur have a business right like
change the mindset immediately start
building your funnel build your list
don't wait for you know two years ago by
before you do anything I think the
advice from my younger self was it for
success on social media I think it would
be um going all in on one platform I
think I spent too much time initially
like and it's fine the test things out
but I was spending too much time trying
to do everything and then ended up doing
everything in a super mediocre way and
not building up some real traction and I
wished I could do more YouTube stuff but
I was being sucked in
I Facebook and Twitter and figuring out
Instagram and you only have so many
hours in a day to do everything I guess
but especially just for social and I
recently just not totally drop but drop
some and spend a little last time on
others so I can go all in on YouTube and
video and it's had insane success so I
think it's hard because everybody's
telling you you see this article like
why linkedin marketing is the future
though I'm not a linkedin I gotta do
better a link day and have more success
there and people kind of push in all
these different directions and you end
up just researching research and
research and not actually doing enough
and so going all in on on on my
strengths I feel really helped me and I
wish I wish I'd done it earlier I guess
but that would be my advice to me and
herself cool Brandon man we're at the
hour this is like I don't think we
touched but me touch me one question
that was in the fridge what's didn't we
had an awesome audience I appreciate the
call in thank you guys for watching
Brandon for more on you people want to
reach out or learn more but what you're
up to what's the best way to do that so
you see my twitter handle there you know
you can you can absolutely tweet me I'm
acted there you could also you know go
check out our a weber blog blog Dani
Weber calm subscribe there there's lots
of awesome education and tips on you
know on just about anything like the
email marketing so that's that's what
I'd recommend doing is going to check
out those those resources cool and for
those of you watching on YouTube on the
repeat i will put Brandon's twitter feed
in the description and brand new if
there's any links freezers you want to
share I'll pop that in the description
too that's good that's it thank you guys
have an amazing day is it Thursday and I
will see you soon thanks for any for
joining all right thanks Evan